Kevin Giles, Filmmaker: First topic of discussion of real
general rule why POC's [People Of Color] with disabilities
are not represented in TV, film, pop,
culture anything? Why do you think that
is? Page Peter Wilson,  Producer/Actor: I think that's an easy one.
I think when it comes to representation
behind the camera there's not enough of
it I think we need to see more people of
color behind the camera I think we need
to see more people with disabilities or
people from the LGBTQ community behind
the camera I think that's of like the
utmost importance I think that more
people telling their own stories it
comes off more genuine and it's it's
more realistic and audiences they pick
up on these things they're getting
smarter and smarter so I think that's
important yeah representation it's all
about representation if you see yourself
or someone looking like you in a place
position group yeah that you otherwise
wouldn't imagine yourself in it changes
your perspective on what is possible for
you
so that should be the number one goal
exactly I guess as far as the film
industry is to continue to expand those
experiences so people start seeing
themselves and start and stop limiting
themselves and what they believe they
can do I think it's as simple as that
agreed all right so our next topic is
what are we doing to change that I think
as filmmakers like what the simplest
thing we can do is if we want to see
those stories we just kind of make those
stories like we got to do it ourselves
we got to take the initiative and go out
and film and tell those stories
ourselves like I definitely agree with
that you know as a filmmaker I can echo
that and as an actor personally I thank
you it's about making a commitment to
work with people from diverse
backgrounds you know I think it's
important to to seek out those projects
that it may be come from a place that's
underrepresented or that you wouldn't
see as much I think that's important
mm-hmm yeah I think inclusivity is a big
key in changing the way we represent
people and when you include those people
who you are talking about in their
experiences and it makes them gentlemen
and make some truthful because when we
see it like if you see somebody try and
tell stories about like a personal
experience by ourselves
and you know they don't experience that
it comes off as this office yeah exactly
completely disingenuous it's not
truthful and I feel like that's the
his problem and the biggest hurdle I
have to get over all right next topic of
discussion unforeseen problems that
almost surround our production anything
like that any stories I think not so
much unforeseen but unpredictable
working with a child actor is hard but
working with a child who is a non act oh
yes that definitely presents his own
unique challenges I think we were able
to work our way work our way through
those but a benefit of that was we got a
lot of genuine and believable reactions
and actions from her but I think that
was definitely a challenge just just
working our way through that yeah I
completely agree I think that was by far
the biggest challenge we had yeah going
into trio our short film I think the
benefit of working with non actors is
that you do you get somebody who has not
trained in a sense to feel a certain
emotion when they're told to feel it
yeah it's just if they're reacting to a
situation so it's all completely natural
because they don't know how to be
anything other than themselves which is
what you want to get for exactly and so
when you're working with a child who's
not an actor it's just like they don't
know what to be other than themselves so
that's exactly what you want you're
getting genuine performance even though
it's not actually a performance you know
it's funny I think when it comes to
working with actors versus not actors
when it when it comes to children I
almost would prefer not actor because
you know it's um sometimes with a child
actor you can come off a little too
refined yeah they're professionals yeah
it's almost like you don't want a child
to be a professional read sense so I
think it's kind of a blessing in
disguise
there's the problems come with like you
know it's it's you're dealing with a kid
who you know doesn't it's they're not
working it's when they have someone they
decide to not yeah they're done working
and then suddenly becomes like oh hey
they can check out it becomes like this
scene could go from taking ten minutes
to an hour because you need to get them
back in the coax them back into it I
need to encourage them to to work with
you and when we experienced some of that
yeah definitely experience that is
definitely something we experience for
sure but I think it was completely worth
it because what you get at the end of
the day is just so much more genuine and
truthful yeah so what do you think was
like one of our biggest challenges on
set
I think biggest challenges like not
talking about unforeseen but like just
biggest challenges straight up it's just
the problem not having the money to pay
the crew I see because you know you know
and like you want to be paid and like
you you understand that everyone wants
to be paid everyone needs to be paid
like you're putting a lot of time and
effort into something in the to of
production and you know not being able
to pay anybody really sucks yeah
especially at this level but we
understood how important the story is to
tell how important and how kind of how
few times this story is told at all like
I can't recall a time where I saw a
person of color who was deaf on film
like I really can't I've seen blind and
like you know you're talking about Ray
Charles like a biopic you know we've
seen that before but like in terms of
like just a character who was a person
of color and had a disability in terms
of deafness I've never seen that before
right I think that's what kind of helped
us encourage the talented crew that we
did put together to come work for us to
come put the time and because they
understood the importance of the story
we were trying to tell so for sure not
and I'll echo that I think that was a
large part of the reason a large part of
why they helped us out because it was it
was a meaningful story was a story that
we hadn't really seen before and a lot
of talents people volunteer their time
and really have the sound that's what
felt independent filmmaking is really
all about hundred percent no doubt yeah
I think now we could talk about any kind
of tips we have that kind of came out of
those challenges that we dealt with on
set so do you have any tips you want to
provide for anybody yeah I think you
know dealing with subject matter like
this you know dealing with someone with
a disability it was important for us to
you know depict that disability
disability as truthfully and
realistically as possible wonderful and
having an expert on set was was vital to
us so what we did we actually had my my
sister on set with us yes who is hearing
impaired she is deaf and 100% fluent
America sign language and that was like
far and away the most hopeful thing for
me as an actor to be able to support to
the side and say hey am I doing this
accurately like is there a different way
that I could that I could say this that
would
come off more truthfully in this
particular circumstance and that was
that helped me like immensely couldn't
agree more like that helped me - that
helped me feel better about the story we
were telling because I don't have I
don't really know anybody who is deaf
and within like my immediate community
at all even person of color or not
so having her onset made me feel so much
better about telling them it made me so
much more confident to tell the story I
have always had her to look for and just
be like how are we doing basically and
just like a lot of thumbs up and that
just made me feel really good about it
I think another tip I definitely provide
and this is coming for more from the
kind of this kind of the filmmaking
aspect yeah I think when it comes to
communicating a disability visually
that's so important because it's not
always easy so when you're talking about
deafness or blindness it's not always
easy to communicate those disabilities
visually because we're working in a
visual medium and I think my biggest tip
to people is to just like take a look at
how other films and filmmakers have
approached those challenges see what
they did and try I think what you always
want to do is try and build off of the
language the cinematic language that has
been set up at previous works from
previous filmmakers I think we're we're
really working in a threat we're really
I think it's always great to be aware of
the history the industry you're working
in and use it to your advantage so if
someone else has dealt with that
challenge in an ingenious kind of way
see what you can do to either build off
a tower gain inspiration from it have
your own thing and make it happen so
yeah I think we did a lot of that with
this well yeah I agree completely